well our Asia correspondent Cordelia
Lynch gave us the latest update from
Delhi
[Music]
rescue workers are at the scene trying
to pull survivors from that mangled
wreckage but hopes a diminishing fast we
also saw villagers overnight rushed to
the scene to try and do whatever they
could and hundreds of people as well
going to hospitals trying to donate
their blood around 900 people have been
taken to hospital with injuries the
prime minister of India at Narendra Modi
will be visiting the site as well as one
of the hospitals trying to provide
Comfort to those survivors but also for
many bereaved families that India is now
dealing with this is a place where
safety standards on trains has long been
a topic of debate we've seen human error
and signaling issues often blamed the
government has tried to make
improvements but this is a system under
great pressure around 12 million people
use around 14
000 trains every day across India
investigation into what occurred in this
crash is now underway